like I said you're typically going to
lead into this so a pot aid might be for
instance consider this guy one plus X to
the N think of the binomial theorem you
can tell me what I should be adding up
here on the right hand side right what
would you like me to put down from okay
let's go in case I could have done int
but it does not from 0 to n of what
what's the general term we've actually
chosen K whatever okay you got to do the
binomial coefficient first and then you
think what I've got some of these got
some of these right for completeness
sake I'm gonna write you some number of
ones okay I want to make this easy for
myself so am I gonna say to the power of
K or am I gonna say to the power of n
minus coconuts okay and then I'm left
with X lots of sorry K lots of X Y a
jerk okay so in a second we're going to
get rid of that factor that multiple of
one groups doesn't matter but from here
I can get to this guy by differentiation
now usually the question will kind of
lead you into that and say by
differentiating both sides of this show
that this is the case but there's
another clue for you that tells you like
this kind of is you know a smoking gun
that says oh this is clearly
differentiation have a look at the line
you'll require to prove which part of
that looks suspiciously like a
derivative but put the right-hand side
to me doesn't it doesn't this look like
a in X 2 then minus 1 that's just
standard definition differentiation okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start
from this line is consider line and I'm
going to differentiate both sides in
different shape resins so if I do that
what am I gonna get off the front I'm
gonna have em
- one gee that looks helpful right you
see bright animated versus one in the
white spots now have a look at this
remember see rotation those needs I want
to add up a whole bunch of these and the
derivative of a sum thankfully for us is
just the sum of each of the individual
derivatives okay so that's really nice
and convenient you're going to get that
mck term front we already know not to
worry about the one what's gonna happen
here okay X to the K minus one okay
right now my task is to say well what's
going to happen to get me from here so
the result I had before now remember you
already have two methods up your sleeve
right and I want you to use one of them
it doesn't u-substitution okay I've got
a 1 plus X but I was supposed to have
two so the obvious choice for X is what
so I'm gonna substitute him in was the
power so I suppose I should have said
you know differentiating both sides with
respect to X that might be helpful
okay so having established that's what I
did I'm now going to put in a value of x
right and I have to do this after can't
do it before because I need it to be
variable in order to differentiate it
but now I think just put a memory okay
so it looks like on the left hand side I
get this which is very promising and on
the right hand side I'm gonna get well
let's have a look at this is k equal to
0 to n okay okay what gets left behind
it's K times 1 to the power of sweet I'm
pretty much done I've done all the
legwork all that's left is actually just
to write out this thing look it's K
times n c k0 it's easier one in c1 I'm
just gonna write it up
remember you just need the three terms
to establish the pattern and you know
pretty so despite the fact that you
maybe thought all nerve
the second method the first method was
okay if the second rent that's in bruja
what's the third method gonna be like
actually calculus made some of these
results just pop out easily okay now I
said you two sides to the same coin
right so example for let's see a kind of
result that needs to be done by
integration so this result looks a
little more icky Scot fractions and
stuff in it and it has this reader thing
which we only are familiar with because
of where do we seen this before this is
the general solution for sine right so
what it's doing is it's having that
switching factor in here okay which by
the way based on that greatest
coefficient question we just did that
should give you a clue as to what kind
of expansion you're going to be
encountering okay so I gave you a big
clue which was okay we did
differentiation here let's try
integration I'm going to start from the
same point okay so if you take this and
you integrate both sides with respect to
X can you tell me what the left-hand
side is gonna become the power it
increases and then I divide through by
my new power
yes how do you think yeah now thankfully
because it's just the inside derivative
just being one my reverse chain rule
doesn't end up being too problematic so
it's that's all you get on the left hand
side what are you on the right hand side
yeah
what's a constant I'm starting from here
yeah so this is a result I'm trying to
prove this will be my final line just on
the first line okay so this kind of like
a hermetically sealed barrier between
here and here I'm using the binomial
theorem which my can court that's the
whole point of the topic I'm using that
is my entry point and I'm integrating
both sides right now oh yeah okay you
with me now all right that's better so
now I've integrated the left-hand side
these the integral of a sum is still the
sum of the integrals I can do every
single one individually which means I'm
gonna have a new sum here from 0 up to n
this n ck is still a constant it's no
big deal and then you've got the one
which doesn't matter and this guy what
is your scratch oh it's fantastic the
power goes up and I divide through by
the new power okay what do you think
yeah cool except no is something missing
I integrated right I integrated and
there were no boundaries for my integral
ok so there is a constant of integration
yeah and I kind of need to work out what
it is ok so again remember how we are we
chose a value here that would get us can
I finish
yeah yeah where was that I chose a value
of x that would get me straight to that
result that was nice but now I have this
constant flying around and clearly I've
got evaluated right so I'm going to
choose another value of x maybe one
maybe something else that is going to
get me to that constant the fastest way
okay so I want as much of this as I
possibly can to just disappear
so one value of x do you think would
work
how about zero zero is really nice
because I'm here on the right hand side
every single one of your terms has a
factor of X in it so if you make a mole
zero everything he just disappears so
I'm gonna say some x equals zero into
this right
what is that leaving with on the left
hand side look carefully you get one
plus zero which is just gonna be one on
that oh look look that's thyme sauce
right and that's gonna be equal to a big
fat zero plus a constant okay so that's
what my concern is therefore coming back
to this line I'm just gonna restate it
but I'm gonna restate it with the value
of the constant now
okay
and once more with feeling of who's not
gonna try to prove has no X's in it so
I've got to choose another value of x
that will get me to this line
I chose evaluate so now at the cluster
now I choose a different value that will
get me to here
what do you reckon
now hmm the tricky thing is right the
tricky thing is I've got these
alternating signs that I have to deal
with okay now remember what I told you
the example we did like 10 minutes ago
is this versus this do you remember that
right so all I need is for one of my
terms to have a negative in it
well the only time I make up my own here
is the X term so if I substitute in x
equals negative 1 ok
it all just comes out and in fact I will
show you my working because we should so
here's my working is monkey you can see
where I've chosen to substitute the
value in just watch out there's one
little thing that's not obvious before
you get to the home stretch okay see
he's me putting in negative 1 right
there you see it see it there okay but
look it's negative 1 to the I plus 1 I
actually don't what R plus 1 right I
want that to Justin ah so that when I
substitute all of these values of R in
the last one would just be N right so I
actually don't want the plus 1 in this
might take it out and take it out is
everything that means every single term
in my son has been multiplied by
negative 1 so I can take it out like
that and that means I can add it to both
sides because it's a negative peak so
I'm just bouncing yeah okay